Apple's iPhone 15 launch is fast
approaching and a lot of you guys are
trying to decide if you should finally
upgrade or wait just one more year in
the hopes of getting a much better
iPhone so fasten your seatbelts Because
by the end of this list of 10 major
leaked iPhone 16 features I'm confident
you'll make up your mind and if you
decide to wait another year don't forget
to subscribe and thank me for saving
your wallet from a huge thousand dollar
haul at least for now jumping right into
iPhone 16 feature number one we have
even larger displays yes you know that
huge 6.7 inch pro Max model that barely
fits in your hands and hurts like heck
when it falls on your face while
accidentally falling asleep in bed yes
that's about to get even bigger next
year according to Ross young the king of
display leaks both the 16 pro and pro
Max models will feature displays that
are about 0.2 inches is larger so 6.3
inches for the 16 Pro and 6.9 inches for
the pro Max that right there is crazy
because seriously the 6.7 inch model is
already huge even for those with big
hands so it's hard to figure out why
Apple would do this in the first place
well there are multiple answers to that
and they're in this video but before
that I want to make it very clear that
only the pro and pro Max models will be
getting those displays the regular
iPhone 16 and 16 plus will continue to
get 6.1 and 6.7 inch displays which is a
smart move by Apple to differentiate the
basic models from the Kings and probably
justify price increases but now getting
into a major explanation for the size
increase of the Pro Models we have
feature number two which is the
Periscope telephoto zoom camera Twitter
leaker unknowns 21 tweeted out that both
the 16 Pro and 16 Pro Max models will
feature the new Periscope lens unlike
the 15 lineup where it's restricted to
the pro Max only yes the main reason the
new Periscope is only coming to the pro
Max this year is quite literally because
the smaller 6.1 inch model doesn't have
enough space on the inside to fit the
large Periscope camera module so there's
a good chance that apple is only
increasing the sizes of the 16 pro and
pro Max models because they need to fit
in that Periscope camera but that still
doesn't explain why the 6.7 inch pro Max
is becoming an even larger 6.9 inch
since I'm sure the current 6.7 can fit
in all of that until you see feature
number three which is massive apparently
the iPhone 16 Pro Max will be getting
another exclusive feature that will
require an even larger size and that's
the addition of a brand new super
telephoto camera giving us a focal
length of over 300 millimeters now to me
that sounds absolutely incredible but if
you have no idea what it means let me
explain because it's gonna blow your
mind and you know what else is going to
blow your mind winning a brand new iPad
10 from our partner cases huge iPad
giveaway that they're running up until
August 8th to celebrate the launch of
their new Cloud Kush iPhone case which
features an air gap in between the frame
for maximum drop protection as well as
raised lips all the way around to
protect your screen and your cameras and
a silky smooth rounded finish that's
incredibly comfy to hold in your hands
and as for the iPad giveaway just use
the links below to make sure you're one
of the first 100 people to enter and if
200 people enter they'll be giving away
two iPads so use those links below to
enter her now back to that 300
millimeter super zoom camera it's crazy
because the current 3x telephoto Zoom
has a focal length of 77 millimeters
which means that 300 millimeter will be
basically a 12x zoom lens which will
have incredible quality and that'll be
on top of the three to six x Periscope
camera coming this year so that's one
reason to wait for the 16 Pro Max now
getting into feature number four we have
the new iPhone Ultra model which Mark
German originally thought was coming
this year but now says is coming next
year but here's a crazy thought what if
that new 6.9 inch display iPhone model
is actually the new Ultra in addition to
the pro Max model coming next year now
that could get a little bit complicated
because that would give us five phones
in the lineup on top of the the se but
what if they're planning to Dish the SEO
altogether seeing as all of the iPhone
se4 leaks have faded away and it seems
like they're getting ready to
discontinue it all together or the pro
Max is simply getting rebranded as the
ultra which makes a whole lot more sense
in terms of having a decently
functioning lineup and then if that were
to happen I would expect the ultra model
to continue having exclusive features
like that super zoom camera that may
never come down to the Pro or regular
models sort of like how the Apple watch
Ultra is right now and if you're
wondering which unique new features we
could end up with on the ultra that
brings us to feature number five solid
state buttons when the rumors for these
buttons first came out we were all 100
sure that they were coming this year
replacing the current tactical volume
and power buttons with brand new haptic
solid state buttons which means they
don't actually move at all and they
depend on sensors to detect when you're
pressing them this was supposed to have
a really cool low power chip that
enables them to work even when the
iPhone is off and include new
customization options as well however we
got the news that they were delayed
until the iPhone 16 light up next year
and even more recently we got news that
they might not be coming to the iPhone
16 Pro Models either but what if they're
actually destined for the new 16 Ultra
model which will have these buttons as
one of the exclusive features honestly
I'm not really sure so let's jump into
number six which is an apple design
modem which will finally replace
qualcomm's 5G modem which has honestly
caused some overheating issues over the
past couple of years especially on the
iPhone 12 lineup and apple might even
integrate their own Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
chips into that single new modem coming
next year and speaking of Wi-Fi feature
number seven is actually the addition of
Wi-Fi seven rumored to come next year
and you basically know what that means
faster and more reliable Wi-Fi I don't
think I need to explain that any further
so let's move on to number eight
according to the elect the iPhone 16 Pro
Models are rumored to feature under
display face ID which means that we
could see the removal of the pill-shaped
cutout which would get replaced with a
small hole punch for just the camera now
I honestly feel like apple would still
keep the dynamic Island around even if
the actual cutout is Tiny and then when
you start watching videos or content in
landscape mode the dynamic Island would
disappear allowing full screen video
with just a little hole punch instead of
the full island and the best part here
is that this leak perfectly lines up
with Ross Young's display timeline for
iPhones and their display features but
keep in mind that the regular I iPhone
16 models will continue to have the
regular pill plus hole punch cut out now
getting into feature number nine this is
yet another one for the 16 Pro Models
and that's a new upgraded main camera
which will be 12 larger than the current
48 megapixel main camera that we have
right now in the pros which will be
staying the same for this year's iPhone
15 lineup so that'll basically give us
another Improvement in terms of low
light photography and faster sensor
readout which is always good and finally
for feature number 10 we have the only
good leak for the regular iPhone 16 and
16 plus models which is hilariously just
a rearranged camera layout to make them
look different from the iPhone 14 and 15
models so if you're still here watching
up to this point first of all thank you
and second of all you care enough about
iPhones to the point where you should
honestly only be buying Pro Models from
now on because that's where all of the
best tech and Innovation is headed so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did subscribe right there and watch
one of our other great videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign